[Música]
steve banon ex estratega de donald trump
fue detenido por un presunto millonario
fraude en la recaudación de fondos para
la construcción del muro en la frontera
con mexico el considerado arquitecto de
la victoria electoral presidencial en
2016 fue arrestado en un yate y se
declaró no culpable
última noche de la convención nacional
demócrata el evento cierra con el
esperado discurso de joe biden en el que
se espera describa su visión para eeuu
en caso de que consiga derrotar a donald
trump el 3 de noviembre tenemos reporte
desde washington
en méxico se filtró un documento del
proceso legal de emilio lozoya acusado
de sobornos ligados a odebrecht y en él
se mencionan nombres de ex presidentes
ex funcionarios y varios políticos a
quienes señala de recibir grandes
cantidades de dinero de la constructora
odebrecht el presidente dijo que de
comprobarse las acusaciones deben
devolver al estado el dinero que
supuestamente obtuvieron ilegalmente
también enlazamos a la capital
hola cómo están buenas noches en américa
latina y a todos ustedes que nos siguen
por la señal de france 24 mi nombre es
alan austria y hoy que es 20 de agosto
sean bienvenidos gracias por compartir
sus jueves con nosotros empezamos en
eeuu y es que en libertad bajo una
fianza de 5 millones de dólares quedo
steve varón considerado como uno de los
artífices de la victoria electoral de
donald trump en 2016
banon es señalado de hacer parte de una
trama fraudulenta recolectando fondos
para el muro fronterizo con méxico que
trump prometió el mandatario aseguró que
desde hace años no tratada con él y es
que el ex asesor de trump es una figura
ultra conservadora muy polémica que
formó parte de la casa blanca hasta
mediados de 2017 veamos este informe de
álvaro cordero
el exasesor de donald trump stick banon
fue detenido por defraudar miles de
dólares de las donaciones para construir
el muro con méxico banon es un
ultraconservador famoso por sus
polémicas y una de las principales
figuras responsables de la victoria de
donald trump en 2016 el departamento de
justicia le acusó junto a otras tres
personas por fraude electrónico su
campaña de financiación del muro llegó a
recaudar hasta 25 millones de dólares
líderes de la campaña de recaudación de
fondos en línea with bill the world
fueron acusados de defraudar a cientos
de miles de donantes bryant colfer steve
finnan y otras dos personas han desviado
presuntamente cientos de miles de
dólares de la organización los cuatro
acusados se beneficiaron de sus roles en
el plan
banon es considerado una de las personas
más influyentes en el pensamiento
ultraderechista sus ideales han quedado
plasmados en diversas producciones de
documentales y sobre todo en el portal
ultraconservador breitbart sus
detractores le han acusado en más de una
ocasión de supremacista blanco misógino
racista
y homófobo y sobre todo por su capacidad
para alimentar la desinformación tras su
partida de la casa blanca su figura ha
tenido una especial influencia en europa
dando apoyo a movimientos euroescépticos
en italia reino unido hungría el
proyecto de integración lo que la unión
europea siempre ha querido está muerto
y éste ya no escucharás a juncker en
bruselas ni a nadie presionando por una
mayor integración entienden que la gente
se alejó de eso la detención de uno de
los ideólogos del proyecto del muro
supone un duro golpe para otra de las
políticas estrella que donald trump
sostuvo en 2016
eeuu comenzó el proceso ante el consejo
de seguridad de la onu para restablecer
sanciones contra la república islámica
de irán el secretario de estado mike
pompeo además pidió que se amplíe el
embargo de armas que está por finalizar
en octubre
washington argumenta que teherán está
violando las condiciones del acuerdo
nuclear de 2015 del que eeuu ya no forma
parte tras haberlo abandonado hace dos
años
rechazó inmediatamente esta medida
asegurando que el haberse retirado del
tratado anula el derecho de proponer
estas sanciones
y seguimos con más noticias de eeuu y es
que estamos a pocas horas para que joe
biden entregue su esperado discurso como
candidato a la presidencia de eeuu que
será la culminación de una convención
nacional demócrata que se ha realizado
virtualmente debido a la pandemia y es
una plataforma importante para los
demócratas pues debido a la crisis del
hobbit 19 los actos de campaña han
quedado reducidos y el presidente de
donald trump ha tenido más oportunidades
de dirigirse a la gente hoy para
boicotear este discurso camps se dirigió
al estado natal de byd en delaware esto
para un acto público el día de hoy se
esperan en la convención los discursos
de cory booker senador por new years eve
pit bridge ex aspirante presidencial
entre otros ayer la jornada estuvo
protagonizada por kamala harris quien
aceptó ser vicepresidenta en fórmula
vicepresidencial con joe biden
escuchamos a nuestra corresponsal diana
castañeda en washington
hola qué tal en este último día de la
convención demócrata se espera el
discurso final de aceptación del
candidato yo bayrén en donde va a hablar
de su plataforma si llega a la casa
blanca en 2021 se espera que bailen
hable del plan de recuperación que tiene
tras la crisis económica por la pandemia
también sus planes para inmigración al
igual que educación acceso a salud
reforma migratoria para más de 20
millones de inmigrantes de origen latino
que viven en los eeuu
también se esperan testimonios de
decenas de ciudadanos estadounidenses
que estarán contando cómo les ha
afectado la pandemia y de esta manera
finalizarán cuatro días de convención
demócrata lo próximo será la convención
republicana que se dará la siguiente
semana
esta noche espere en nuestro cuarto
especial informativo sobre el discurso
del candidato demócrata a la presidencia
de eeuu joe biden a partir de las 8 de
la noche hora de bogotá quito lima y
ciudad de méjico escucharemos y
analizaremos los últimos eventos que
cerraran la convención nacional
demócrata
y seguimos en eeuu y es que los
incendios han devorado 142 mil hectáreas
en california las autoridades ordenaron
nuevas evacuaciones ante el rápido
avance de los fuegos forestales masivos
en el centro y norte del estado que han
creado enormes columnas de humo en la
zona de san francisco 1 donde los
mayores focos de fuego abarca los
condados de napa y sonoma donde ha
consumido más de 53.000 hectáreas y
sigue fuera de control
en el vecino del sur en mexico se filtró
un documento del proceso legal de emilio
lozoya acusado de sobornos ligados a la
empresa brasileña odebrecht en la
declaración el alto funcionario del
gobierno del ex presidente enrique peña
nieto- denuncia a los ex mandatarios
felipe calderón y carlos salinas junto a
otros políticos algunos de ellos hoy
ocupan cargos de gobernadores y también
se mencionan ex altos funcionarios entre
ellos los ex candidatos presidenciales
josé antonio meade y ricardo anaya
escuchamos a nuestro corresponsal en la
capital mexicana mario carbonell
emilio lozoya y director de pemex ha
destapado la caja de pandora haciendo
una serie de acusaciones que han
cimbrado a la clase política ha señalado
de corrupción a tres ex presidentes de
la república enrique peña nieto- felipe
calderón y carlos salinas de gortari
además de a una decena de ex
funcionarios y ex legisladores todo ello
a través de una denuncia penal que el
propio lozoya hizo ante la fiscalía
general de la república y que ha sido
filtrada a los medios de comunicación en
esta denuncia señala por ejemplo a peña
nieto- de haber sobornado legisladores
para que le aprobaran sus reformas
estructurales a felipe calderón lo
señala de haber tenido contratos
leoninos con braskem socia de odebrecht
y a carlos salinas de haber presionado
para favorecer los negocios de uno de
sus hijos algunos de los implicados han
salido a defenderse es el caso de
ricardo anaya ex candidato presidencial
del pan quien incluso interpuso una
demanda por daño moral
asimismo luís videgaray quien fuera
secretario de hacienda de peña nieto- y
señalado como el principal orquestador
de toda esta trama
lo que va a proceder legalmente el
propio ex presidente calderón dice que
el oso ya está siendo utilizado como un
instrumento de venganza y persecución
política a todo esto el presidente
andrés manuel lópez obrador ha dicho que
la denuncia filtrada es auténtica y que
quienes están señalados si no hicieron
nada indebido no tienen nada que temer
la fiscalía general de la república
asegura que no salió la filtración de
esta dependencia por lo que es una
incógnita pero la pregunta también es
qué consecuencias penales habría en caso
de que alguna de las acusaciones de la
soya resulte cierta
el gobierno interino de bolivia presentó
este jueves una denuncia penal contra el
ex presidente evo morales- por estupro y
tráfico de personas la presentación
tiene lugar luego de que tomara estado
público una supuesta relación entre el
ex mandatario y una menor la mujer en
cuestión indicó que conoció al ex
presidente cuando tenía 16 años y dijo
que están enamorados desde mayo de este
año
dejamos el continente americano y nos
vamos a rusia y es que el líder opositor
a alexéi navalni duro crítico del
presidente vladimir putin se encuentra
hospitalizado esto luego de que
presentará síntomas de envenenamiento
durante un vuelo en dirección a moscú
naval y está en estado de coma con un
respirador artificial
el kremlin aseguró que cualquier
envenenamiento deberá ser confirmado con
pruebas de laboratorio
andrés amaya nos cuenta más en el
siguiente informe
y el avión en el que viajaba alexéi
navalni tuvo que hacer una parada de
emergencia ya que su estado empeoró
luego de haber tomado una taza de té en
el aeropuerto de la ciudad de tomsk a
las afueras de la clínica donde fue
hospitalizado su médico confirmó la
sospecha de un envenenamiento
álex ella está en estado grave pero
estable se trata de una intoxicación con
un agente desconocido encefalopatía
tóxica está en coma
pero sí que es cierto modo
noval y es un feroz crítico del
presidente ruso vladimir putin en junio
describió la votación sobre la reforma
constitucional de rusia como un golpe de
estado pues permitirá al mandatario
quedarse en el poder otros dos mandatos
más la portavoz del opositor informó que
noval y será trasladado lo más pronto
posible si la familia y los médicos de
alexéi navalni tomaron la decisión de
trasladarlo a otra clínica al menos
había que hacerlo porque en homs en el
hospital donde se encuentra ahora mismo
no hay equipo suficiente para realizar
todas las pruebas y procedimientos
necesarios además debe hacerse por
cuestiones de seguridad
por su parte el portavoz del gobierno
ruso dijo que no se opondrán sin aval ni
tiene que seguir un tratamiento en el
extranjero
a pesar de que las fronteras están
cerradas muchos de nuestros ciudadanos
viajan al extranjero para recibir
tratamiento por supuesto estaríamos
listos para investigar urgentemente esas
solicitudes si las hubiera
varias personas protestaron en san
petesburgo tras el presunto
envenenamiento del líder de la oposición
esta no sería la primera vez que una
sustancia nociva es utilizada contra
opositores políticos a la lista de
envenenamiento se suma el de peor ver si
love activista y miembro del grupo puso
riots y el del ex agente ruso serguéi
skripal y su hija giulia
el presidente de belarús alexander
lukashenko ha ordenado investigar las
protestas en su contra y a los miembros
de la oposición ante esta decisión la
unión europea ha decidido tomar cartas
en el asunto que incluyen sanciones a
líderes del gobierno de lukashenko ayer
el bloque desconoció las elecciones que
le dieron la victoria a lukashenko quien
lleva 26 años en el poder
y nos vamos a mali y es que los partidos
de la coalición de oposición dieron su
apoyo a la junta militar que dio el
golpe de estado el martes ocasionando la
salida del poder del presidente ibrahim
boubacar keita en una entrevista para
france 24 el portavoz de la junta ismael
uaga ha señalado que habrá un presidente
de transición horas después de que los
países de áfrica occidental anunciarán
el envío de una delegación para ayudar a
garantizar el regreso del orden
gubernamental
y mire para finalizar los escolares de
tailandia se han sumado a la ola de
protestas antigubernamentales iniciadas
en julio por los universitarios para
acabar con la influencia de los
militares precisamente en la política
exigiendo reformas constitucionales y
monárquicas en este país vamos a este
informe de marina sardina
con cintas blancas en el pelo y
levantando tres dedos al aire durante el
matutino himno nacional los estudiantes
de secundaria de tailandia se unen a la
ola de protestas antigubernamentales
como desafío el autoritarismo del
sistema educativo y político que prima
la jerarquía y la obediencia
estamos aquí para hacerles saber que ya
no toleramos lo que no está bien
queremos que las cosas se arreglen y
dawa desde mediados de julio los jóvenes
universitarios han salido a las calles
de la capital bangkok pese a las
restricciones por la pandemia los
manifestantes piden el fin de la marcada
influencia de los militares en la
política nacional y demandan reformas en
la constitución incluida la intocable
casa real la disolución del parlamento y
la celebración de nuevos comicios el
miércoles 6 activistas prodemocracia
fueron detenidos entre ellos este
abogado de derechos humanos debemos
poder hablar de esta monarquía
públicamente hablar con respeto por el
régimen y la institución de la monarquía
si no lo discutimos nunca podremos
solucionar el problema
el principal objetivo de las marchas es
el primer ministro para chan ocha es
jefe del ejército que dio un golpe de
estado en 2014 y que ha permanecido en
el poder tras las controvertidas
elecciones de 2019
llegamos al final de esta emisión les
agradecemos mucho su compañía ya lo sabe
siga con nosotros en las noticias aquí
en france 24 y cuídense crece mucho del
hobbit 19
[Música]